and in another high-stakes phone call us
president joe biden has been speaking
with chinese leader xi jinping to
discuss the ukraine situation president
biden was expected to ask president xi
and not to provide any military or
economic assistance for russia's war
against ukraine the u.s believes
president putin informed china about its
invasion plans in advance
during talks in beijing in
in february president xi and mr putin
pledged limitless friendship between
their two countries
so let's explore what's likely to be
happening behind the scenes with dw's
chief international editor richard
walker welcome richard president biden
has quite publicly threatened what he
called costs if china assists russia in
this war what are those costs likely to
be well well there are kind of two
levels to this fill on the on the one
hand the u.s could move uh to imposing
sanctions on chinese banks or other
institutions if it perceives that they
are trying to break or sidestep
the sanctions that the united states has
imposed on russia these things are
called secondary sanctions so if if you
break the sanctions that we put on
russia then we put sanctions on you
so so that's one step that they could do
but there's another potential level to
this a more serious one and that is what
happens if china does start to provide
russia with military support
and if that happens then we're entering
really quite dangerous territory because
the war in ukraine would then start to
look like a proxy war between china
supporting russia and the west
supporting ukraine
and proxy wars these were these were the
stuff of the cold war these were the
sort of the side battles that the us and
russia during those times fought between
each other through these proxies
we could be entering a really severe
cold war type confrontation if china
goes down that road
with china russia on one side europe and
the united states on the other okay so
what is china's position public position
on this war well china's been professing
quite a sort of independent position and
it says that it wants peace and security
for all that it stands by
things like territorial integrity the
the sovereignty of individual countries
and xi jinping has been talking about
peace and security and some of the
early reporting surrounding the phone
call with um joe biden but the reality
is that china has been rhetorically
quite
aligned with russia
and it's been openly supporting russia's
complaints in particular about nato
about the expansion of nato into eastern
europe
uh russia's concerns that ukraine was
going to join nato
and
analysts say that really this does seem
to be a genuine belief by the chinese
particularly xi jinping
that the united states and nato provoked
this war
by expanding into what they see as
russia's backyard it's sphere of
influence now i spoke to one uh
senior american expert on chinese
foreign policy uh to explain a little
bit about the background to this
position let's take a listen
i think that xi jinping believes that
the united states is now implacably
hostile toward china he saw this start
under the republicans and the trump
administration and now continue under
the biden administration and i think he
has therefore attached more value to
russia and has tilted uh quite decidedly
decisively towards uh toward russia in
this uh this war in ukraine
so according to this reading of xi
jinping he is bracing and preparing for
this long confrontation with the united
states and with the west and sees russia
as an important partner in preparing for
that
right and is there any sign of that
changing
well the trouble is for china that
this war is actually proving a problem
for it
um it's creating huge instability in the
world markets we've seen the prices of
commodities oil and natural gas
wheat grain other commodities all
shooting up
china is very heavily dependent on
fossil fuel imports so this is bad for
china's economy
instability in the world economy is just
generally bad for the chinese economic
model because it's the biggest sporting
power it needs good access to to
export markets
um so all of this is bad plus it's
potentially dangerous for china's
reputation in the world with russia so
isolated if china is one of the last you
know countries standing by russia
standing by russia while we see
atrocities taking place in ukraine
so xi jinping does face something of a
dilemma here
about whether to
really kind of double down on that
relationship with russia and confront
the west or whether to see whether it
can put a little bit of distance between
itself and russia and maybe quietly
through back channels try to get
vladimir putin to move to some sort of
police peace agreement this is what the
americans certainly hope china will do
okay so that's that's china russia let's
talk about
china and the u.s because
where are relations now between those
two countries because
away from this
during the trump era we saw uh sanctions
we saw uh trade embargoes we saw all
sorts of uh things going on so they're
not friends clearly well
donald trump certainly made sort of
attacking china one of the centerpieces
of his presidency although he did uh
come up with with a partial trade deal
with the chinese
um but i think this refers back to what
we were just talking to earlier earlier
it is true that in the united states a
growing consensus has established itself
not just in the republican party not
just
sort of around donald trump but among
the democrats too this is one of the few
areas in american politics where you do
have bipartisan agreement that china is
the big geopolitical problem for them of
this century
and they need to take a tougher line
against it it just so happens at the
moment that of course
china is one of the few countries in the
world that if it were minded to could
potentially get russia it could have
some leverage over russia to de-escalate
this situation so it does put it it's a
very very delicate situation in world
affairs right now okay so
if the old sanctions let's call them
against china the old u.s sanctions
against china are still in place what
else then
would president biden be able to throw
at this situation well i mean
the level of sanctions for instance over
xinjiang you know the the the the um
oppression of the uyghurs that that has
been taking place in in
the western uh province of xinjiang in
china they're not anything like on the
kind of level of sanctions that we've
seen the united states impose on russia
but i would kind of go back to what we
were saying earlier there are a couple
of levels of things that could take
place if the united states decides that
china is trying to breach uh sanctions
on russia it could impose these
secondary sanctions the big problem is
if china supports it militarily right
thank you for that uh richard water uh
walker dw international editor thanks
very much
you